because shyness can grip us in such
powerful ways it's tempting to think of
it as an immutable part of our emotional
makeup with roots that extend far into
our personalities and perhaps biology
and that we were being capable of ever
extirpating but in truth shyness is
based on a set of ideas about the world
that are eminently amenable to change
through a process of reason because they
are founded on some touchingly malleable
errors of sort China's is rooted in a
distinctive way of interpreting
strangers the shy aren't awkward around
everyone they're tongue-tied around
those who seem most unlike them on the
basis of a range of surface markers age
class tastes habits beliefs backgrounds
or religions with no one kindness meant
we could define shyness as a form of
provincialism of the mind an over
attachment to the incidentals of one's
own life and experience but unfairly
casts others into the role of daunting
unfathomable unknowable foreigners on
contact with a person from another world
or province the shy allow their minds to
be dominated by a forbidding aura of
difference they may silently and
awkwardly say to themselves but there's
nothing to be said or done because the
other is famous while they belong to the
province of the obscure or because the
other is very old while their province
is firmly that of twenty-somethings or
because the other is very clever while
their province is that of the
non-intellectual or because the other is
from the land of very beautiful girls
while they hail from the province of
average-looking boys this is why there
can be no grounds to laugh hazard a
playful remark or feel at ease the shy
person doesn't contend to be unpleasant
or unfriendly they simply experience all
other nests as an insurmountable barrier
to making their own goodwill and
personality apparent we can imagine that
in the history of humanity shyness was
always the first response the people
over the hill would have triggered the
feeling because they were farmers while
you were fishermen or they spoke with a
lilt in their vowels while your diction
was
on atone and flat yet gradually there
emerged a more worldly less exclusive
way of relating to strangers what we
might call a psychological
cosmopolitanism in the ancient
civilizations of Greece and Rome
prompted by ever-increasing encounters
between peoples who lived very different
and mutually unfamiliar lives thanks the
developments in trade and shipping an
alternative to shyness developed Greek
travelers who worshiped human-like
divinities learnt that Egyptians revere
cats and certain birds Romans who shave
their chins met barbarians who did not
senators who lived in colonnaded houses
with underfloor heating encountered
chieftains who lived in drafty wooden
huts and among certain thinkers an
approach developed that proposed that
all these humans whatever their surface
variations shared a common call and that
it was to this that the mature mind
should turn in contact with apparent
other nests it was to this cosmopolitan
mindset that the Roman playwright and
poet Terence gave voice when he wrote I
am human
so nothing human is foreign to me and
that Christianity made use of in
rendering universal sympathy a
cornerstone of its view of existence
someone becomes a cosmopolitan not on
the basis of having a buoyant or
gregarious nature but because they are
in touch with a fundamental truth about
humanity because they know that
irrespective of appearance we are the
same species beneath an insight that the
tongue-tied guests at the party or the
awkward seducer in the restaurant a
guilty of implicitly refusing
traditionally rank or status have been
major sources of shy provincialism that
peasant felt he couldn't approach the
Lord
the young milkmaid stammered when the
Earl's son visited the stable today in
an echo of such inhibitions the boy of
average looks feels he could never hang
out with a beautiful girl or the
modestly off will lose any ability to
talk to the very wealthy the mind just
fixates on the Gulf my nose looks like a
child modeled it out of plasticine yours
as if it had been carved out by
Michelangelo I fear losing my job while
you fear that the expansion of your
business into Mexico won't
is profitable as you'd forecast the
cosmopolitan is well aware of
differences they just refused to be
cowed or dominated by them they look
beyond them to perceive or in practical
terms simply to guess at a collective
species unity shyness does have its
insightful dimensions it's infused with
an awareness that we might be bothering
someone with our presence it's based
upon an acute sense that a stranger
could be dissatisfied or
discomforted by us the shy person is
touchingly alive to the dangers of being
a nuisance yet in most cases we simply
pay an unnecessarily heavy price for our
reserve around people who might well
have open their hearts to us only we'd
known how to manifest our own
benevolence we cling to jealously to our
province the pimply boy doesn't discover
that he and the high school Beauty share
a tasting humor and a similarly painful
relationship with their father races and
ages continue not to mingle to their
collective detriment shyness is a
touching yet ultimately excessive and
unwarranted way of feeling special
you